we're just coming to grips with a
stunning fact over 90% of our solar
system begins where the planets and
by the time the sun's light reaches out
that far it's desperately weak but we
knew something was out there because it
kept sending us visitors comets
it was proposed that they came from a
mysterious disc out being on the orbit
of Neptune but no one thought it would
be proven
the Kuiper belt was theoretical was
thought to exist but it was also thought
that it would be too hard to observe
you're talking about objects which maybe
a hundred miles across but there are
billions of miles away trying to find
something that's much much smaller would
be incredibly difficult and no one
really thought you could do it in 1986 a
team of astronomers based at Hawaii's
Mauna Kea Observatory decided to prove
them wrong I'm a bit of a hoarder
these are the notes that we took while
we were observing I used to write lots
of things in a notebook to try to keep
track of everything that was happening
on the mountaintop here's the name of
the telescope the 88 inch telescope on
Mauna Kea also known as the rust-bucket
visitors to that telescope always think
it's the ugliest thing they've ever seen
is painted Brown it looks like it's
totally rusty parts of it are rusty so
it's a horrible looking telescope but we
use it for all of our work if they could
locate an object beyond the planets it
would have to inhabit the ghostly Kuiper
belt for six years they found nothing it
was like trying to find a rusty dime in
the state of Texas we spent many many
years looking for objects in the outer
solar system
lots of pain frankly lots of
disappointment you have to really have
some respect for the scale of objects
yes we can see stars that are hundreds
or thousands of light years away but
they're these giant glowing objects how
do you see something that's only a
hundred miles across and it's dark it's
not giving off any visible light of its
own that's why finding these things have
been difficult Kuiper belt objects are
made of mostly ice
so you'd think they'd Sparkle like
icebergs we're on a volcanic country so
some of these icebergs are actually dark
covered in ash and there are perfect
analogy for a Kuiper belt object so I
really wanted to get close to this one
but my guides just told me that this
one's too big we can't get close it
might flip over all right we found a
really cool one it's really dark get
over here
so you see how black this thing is on
the outside well
comets are also black but actually
they're even blacker than this we think
that comets typically are blacker than
asphalt blacker than tar the ink-black
Kuiper belt objects stayed hidden for
half a decade then one summer night
Jewett and his team spotted something
and the solar system would never be the
same so here's the log sheet the notes
that we keep while we're observing 29th
of August 1992 we started as normal
looking at the images as they came out
of the telescope and found this first
object it was a single tiny dot moving
very slowly across the sky and it's slow
path showed it was orbiting the Sun but
in an orbit that took it way beyond the
planets an orbit that would put it in
the mysterious Kuiper belt it was moving
incredibly slowly across the sky and
therefore was incredibly far away and we
knew just from the slow speed we knew
immediately it was the most distant
object ever seen in the solar system up
to that point
here's this note SM Oh slow moving
object question mark so that's the
discovery of the Kuiper belt right there
where there's three tiny little letters
in an instant the Kuiper belt became
real and our solar system became twice
as large